- Hey, good humans.
Do you love our spectrum videos?
If so, we now have a game
where you can play it at home
with your friends and family.
You can answer questions like this,
Dress codes are sexist.
See what your dad says.
(pop music)
♪ Aoi aoi ano sora ♪
- We can end it right now.
(all laughing)
(techno music)
My name is Christian St. Peter.
I'm from Long Beach, California.
I work for the north
American Collegiate League
which is a nonprofit
collegiate eSports league.
- [Interviewer] What character are you?
- I'm Luffy D. Monkey from One Piece.
For me, it's the entertainment factor.
It's not even necessarily
about wanting to be
in a character or anything like that, but
like the way other people react to you
is what does it for me.
(pop music)
- [Interviewer] You wanna
try guessing each one?
- Oh, wow!
I'm gonna do terribly.
(giggling)
Number one, I see purple boots.
I have no idea.
First thought that comes to mind
is somebody who rides a motorcycle.
No idea why.
Second, is definitely
Annabelle, a horror movie.
Third, Sailor Moon?
(laughing) I have no idea.
Fourth, I'm kind of scared of her
with those boots on to be honest.
I'm gonna be careful what I say to her.
And then fifth is Nezuko?
I forget, but it's the
sister from Demons Slayer.
I'm also probably wrong about that.
We have the most important
question coming up early.
What is your favorite anime?
- "Sailor Moon"
- Quick and to the point.
All right.
Number two.
- "Kakegurui"
I haven't seen that one,
but I'll add it to my list.
- I really like "No game, No life"
because it's what got me into singing
any song in Japanese music.
- Oh, so you're about to bust
out with Bluebird right now or
♪ Aoi aoi ano sora ♪
- We can end it right now.
(all laughing)
All right.
Number four?
- Okay, confession time.
- Uh-oh
- I'm not a huge anime fan.
Don't kill me.
- Okay. Not huge, not huge, but you watch.
- Not huge, not huge, OK
but I do have a favorite anime.
- All right, there we go.
And that is "Inuyasha".
- Okay
- I love me some Inuyasha.
- Okay.
- I used to stay up
Saturday night trying to
force myself to stay awake to watch
that episode on Adult Swim.
- On cartoon network.
- Yes.
- Love that.
I think "Inuyasha" was
probably my first one too
that I like remember watching.
- Oh
- Yes.
- Number five.
- Oh "One Piece" is my favorite enemy.
Happy 1000th Episodes by the way.
(clapping)
(contestant 5 laughing)
What's your favorite Anime?
- So, this gonna come to a
shock when y'all come see me
but, it's actually "Naruto".
- [All Contestants] Ooh
- Yeah. I'm on "Boruto" right now, still
so, I'm still watching
it as it's coming out.
(bell dings)
Oh man.
I'm gonna feel bad no
matter who comes out.
Well, first of all, y'all all lovely.
- [All Contestants] Aww, thank you.
- So I'm just have to
get rid of number one.
I'm sorry.
(upbeat music)
- Good rect.
(Christian laughing)
I would never ride a
motorcycle in my life.
- I'm sorry.
- You're totally fine.
- Well your...
- Huh? -
- Your costume's amazing.
- Thank you.
- And I mean, yeah,
the only reason I got rid
of you is I really just
didn't feel anything.
- Yeah, no problem.
And I thought you have
a really cool voice.
Are you a baritone?
- I'm just a dude.
(All laughing)
- Okay well, it was nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you too.
- Yeah, bye.
(bell dings)
- Okay. Bit different things
than what I was expecting.
I Like the chain. (Christian laughs)
I do see like the bottom of
like a French maids outfit.
- Yeah.
- And some purple coming out.
- Not entirely sure yet.
And then number three
reminds me of Pepe Le Pew so
- Oh, okay
- That's a thing.
I'm just getting attacked
by colors right now.
And it's a good thing.
I like it have
- A tail.
- Oh. And the tail that I did not see.
Looks like a "Monsters, INC".
(all laughing)
- Don't take it the wrong
way, I think its cool.
I myself are coming out of a
very long term relationship.
So what is the longest
relationship that you've been in?
- The longest relationship I've
been in is, was three years
- And then number two.
- So my longest relationship
was three years.
That ended in my first year of university,
at the end of my first year of university.
- And then number three?
- My longest relationship has been
about eight months actually.
That relationship ended in 2017.
- Oh wow
- I am just really looking for someone
who we really compliment one another
and we have a lot of compatibility.
- And then I'm number four.
- My longest relationship
was also three years.
- Dang.
- Yeah.
(Contestants laughing)
- Did you guys like all
date, the same guy or
- Three's the magic number
- No they're not the same guy
they're actually the same person.
- Oh!
- Makes sense.
- He broke up with me and you know,
- I'm sorry.
- No, don't be sorry.
But I feel like it was actually
a blessing to me, you know
finding my independence, going
back to childhood hobbies
like anime, of course.
Cosplay, I had always wanted
to ever since middle school
and you know, I've
explored so many things, so
many creative outlets
like streaming on Twitch,
you know, in my free time.
(bell dings)
- This one's gonna pain me
but I'm afraid I have to
get rid of number three.
- Okay.
- Bye, I love you.
- Oh!
- Hi
- I'm sorry Storm.
- It's okay.
- Obviously only being in
an eight month relationship
I would've liked to hear bigger number.
(both laughing)
Okay. But you're gorgeous
and I love your outfit.
- Thank you.
And you're handsome too.
- I appreciate it.
- I'm hurt, It's fine.
It's fine.
(both laughing)
bell dings
(romantic music)
(Christian laughing)
- Why do you cosplay?
- I cosplay because I like
to feel like the character
that I'm trying to
cosplay, for example, like
I mean, realistically, I can't
be a gremlin in real life
but I love that movie, the "Gremlins
and I wanna be Greta from "Gremlins".
Overall, my style is already, you know
very much creative and artistic.
So I think that when I
cosplay, I kind of feel
like it kind of satisfies
my, you know, creativity.
- Oh. So did...
Number two?
- I almost feel like more like myself,
or that I can be myself
when I'm in cosplay.
Like when I'm with other
people who are cosplaying
and they recognize my cosplay,
I just get filled with
so much positive energy
and I feel like I can radiate
that positive energy to others.
- And then number three
- I cosplay because life
is too short to look basic.
- Thank you.
(all clapping)
- Life is too short.
If you were in an MMORPG or
if you were characterizing
your Sims, you would
not want to look basic.
I actually stream in my cosplay actually.
- Same.
- You do!
- Yeah.
Oh, Nope.
No way.
- Yes way.
- Oh My God!
- That's actually, when I mainly wear it.
You know if you guys don't mind,
are you able to do like
the best impression of your character?
(giggling)
- All right, this is, I'm sorry if this
makes anybody cringe.
Hi, I'm Yamako
- Hi Yamako.
(both laughing)
- Number two?
(speaking Japanese)
(Christian laughing)
- And then number three.
- It'll be our little secret.
- Our what?
(bell dings)
I don't want to, but we don't have to.
So, the first one I'm going
to eliminate is number one.
(upbeat music)
Hi
- Hello, Hi, Nice to meet you.
- Well, I still like your costume.
- Thank you!
Yeah, Yumeko from "Kakegurui".
It's like a gambling type of thing.
- Yeah, no I've seen like
- The cover of it, probably?
- Yeah, the cover.
- You should watch it definitely.
- I'll add it on the list.
- Yeah.
Well, it was nice to meet you.
- You as well.
- Thank you.
- Can we get a drum roll?
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
(shoes tapping)
- So next one I'm eliminating is
the current number one.
- Oh, so that's me?
- That's you.
- Yeah.
- I'm sorry.
Hi.
- Hi!.
- Well you look great.
- Thank you so much.
- No problem, and I'm so happy
you sang "Bluebird" for me.
- Oh, Thank you!
- I'm happy, always happy to sing.
- Appreciate it.
- Yeah.
- Seemed pretty cool.
I appreciate that.
- Yeah. I also really love your cosplay.
That's awesome.
- I tried.
- Yeah.
- Thank you so much.
- [Interviewer] Alright
are you ready to see
your final pick?
- I'm ready.
- [Interviewer] Come on out.
- Lucy, I'm coming.
- Hi. Oh, wow.
- Hi
That's a lot going on.
I mean, it looks great.
- Nice to meet you.
- What's your name?
- Brandee
- Brandee, Christian.
- Like the alcohol
- There we go.
- Do y'all discord?
I'll add you.
- We'll add each other on discord.
- Yes, I do.
Oh my God.
We have watching common.
- We do
- [Interviewer] Are you
guys exchanging Twitches
instead of phone numbers?
- Yeah.
You know, phone numbers for
old people, all discord now.
- Yeah, discord
- you might be in her DMS.
I'm on her discord.
- [Interviewer] What couples costume
do you think you guys could pull off?
- I can be Boa Hancock.
- That'll work.
- You're Loffy
- I'll be Loffy
- I mean, it would work out.
- [Interviewer] Can you two imagine
going on a date potentially?
- Definitely.
E-sports lounge?
- Please?
- Yeah, let's go.
- (laughing) We're about to be so cool
Oh My God!